the way through the challenge is to get
still and ask yourself what is the next
right move not think about it oh I got
all of this too but what is the next
right move and then from that space make
the next right move and the next right
move and not to be overwhelmed by it
because you know your life is bigger
than that one moment you know you're not
defined by what somebody says is a
failure for you because failure is just
there to point you in a different
direction nothing about my life is lucky
nothing
a lot of grace a lot of blessings a lot
of divine order but I don't believe in
luck for me luck is preparation meeting
the moment of opportunity there is no
luck without you being prepared to
handle that moment of opportunity what I
would say for myself is is that because
of my hand in a force greater than my
own I have been prepared in ways that I
didn't even know I was being prepared
for and the truth is for me and for
every person every single thing that has
ever happened in your life is preparing
you for the moment that is to come you
just watched two amazing clips from
Oprah Winfrey take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]